Trump has released a book where he's
published letters that he's received
over the years one of your letters is
front and center I heard about that okay
back in 2000 you wrote him too bad we're
not running for office what a team he I
think he'd written a book and said that
he wanted me to be his running mate if
he decided to yeah if he decided to run
and when I heard that this letter is now
going to be a part of a book I thought
oh wasn't that nice of me to write a
note that's what I thought because I'm
always like oh I should write a note the
person did this or I should write a note
so I'm really happy that I wrote a note
yeah it just shows you have good manners
but you're not thinking you and Donald
Trump would be a team no you were
thinking I might have thought it back
then I might have thought it 23 years
ago yes are you thinking that today no
I'm not thinking okay you want to clear
that up